okay now the angular they alternate
segments often quite hard to spot it's
quite hard to spot so this time I want
you to just redraw this diagram again
redraw the diagram again maybe draw it a
little smaller draw a tangent any
tangent like that and the way you can do
this is you're actually a triangle
inside the circle a triangle that
touches all the points on the
circumference so long as it touches the
point of contact as well any triangle
you like okay so I'm going to draw this
one left you here we go now you might
have noticed the astute among you might
have noticed that there are actually two
angles in the alternate segment
depending on which side you're looking
at okay so let me come back to my colors
this time I'll do it the same let's have
a look at this one
here have a look at this guy there's an
angle between the tangent and the court
of contact you see that I better put
some names on this now so this is taking
the D suggestion let's call this point T
for tangent so the tangent let's call
this P and Q because they're on the
circle have I go more big so now I need
to do the end let's call this n n ok so
I just labeled in orange angle mt p mt p
what's the angle in the alternate
segment what's its name
hmm I think I think I heard it angle P Q
T is probably the way out to
alphabetical as much as possible P Q T
that's the angle in the alternate
segment do you see it can you actually
see how it's like okay look at look at
the two segments that have been created
here there's this one in the small
segment and there's this one in the big
segment you see that but there's another
angle in the alternate segment because
your tangents have two cords of contact
two of them let me get my green now see
this guy over here now you put a big
factor you got there you go there's
another angle between the tangent it's
just a different chord of contact so
what is the angle your tenant segment
for this guy
tpq isn't it over there okay so it's a
bit trippy because it looks sort of
weird
years and years ago like even before I
was um I was at school if you draw a
diagram for this property that looks
like this or something like this and you
draw it up right it sort of looks like I
don't know if anyone's seen like those
it's like a surfboard but it's got a
sail on it and they sort of like they
you know so people call this they
actually called this the wind surfer
theorem please don't write the wind
surfer theorem but that's what they
actually got it because that's kind of
what it looks like not a good idea
because like 95% of the time it actually
doesn't look anything like a wind surfer
you're like what is that guy it's like
when surfing on the moon or something
anyway so the key though is if you've
got the teacher in the court of contact
look carefully and where the two
segments are generally speaking is a big
line then there's more one but you can
do it anywhere you like you still get
the same property okay all right excuse
me
so we're now up to if you have a look on
your sheet now we've actually done up to
11 we've done up to 11 and we've also
done 15 let's talk to them because
you've had some time
number one we should be able to all do
number one number one I'll give you a
tip it's that four equal so I shouldn't
steal your assertion still has everyone
taken why don't we offer you equal
chords data spare awkward equal chords
subtend or form will make equal angles
at birth now you might be tempted to say
circumference you might be tempted to
say circumference however I want to
point out to you have to be very careful
for example here's a chord here's a
chord let's call these guys equal okay
so when you think about angles at the
circumference you might say Oh an angle
over here
but have a look at the other equal cord
you can make a lot of angles off that
cord in fact you can make an infinite
number of angles how do we get this guy
I think it's going to be equal so these
are not going to be equal the
emphatically not going to be equal
because what I've done is I've sort of
gone in the wrong segment okay
I just make it very awkward to say so a
better way to say it or a more
appropriate way because actually correct
is that they're not equal end was in the
circumference they're equal angles at
the center because if you're centering
there's only one Center you can't get
that side wrong for the cord okay so
this guy here that one there has to be
equal to that one there no matter where
you position those cords form of the
equal length we're going to keep on
talking about equal chords so number two
equal quads are they're equidistant from
the center sorry that the lives are a
little bit too small to fit I was trying
to cram it all in one page which I
successfully did but then you have to
write really small serve it up now the
last one is a bit tricky the life of the
be tricky because it uses it whether
you're familiar with but not in a way
that you're familiar with so when you
have something aligned as perpendicular
or something else okay you actually can
call that line a perpendicular that's a
bit awkward perpendicular is usually an
adjective but you can use it as a noun
okay so property three is the
perpendicular from the center right so
let's do it this looks like use mccord
because this is a cord property right
here's my Center and here is my
perpendicular from the center that's
what I just drew this guy that's the
perpendicular what what is it the
perpendicular front rather bisect from
the center to a chord bisects they call
it chops it in half like so now just
before we leave off this one we want to
be angles I hope you remember that
property number three you can say it in
at least two other ways you can say it
at least two other ways for instance you
could say the bisector of a cord passes
through the center that make sense the
bisect different record are the
perpendicular sorry the perpendicular
bisector of court
to the center or alternately you could
say the bisector to the center is
perpendicular to the court since all the
same property but you're just depending
on what your phrase you've been supplied
you just say it from a different angle
so have a look at four five six seven
eight the angle at third we just use
this one of the proof angle that here it
is Center right is twice the angle at
the circumference on the same arc so we
use that one property five we haven't
used this one but it's very easy
OOP yeah if you've got a diameter like
that you've created an angle in a
semicircle like that right oh by the way
I didn't point this out before because I
forgot but this is a lovely application
of this guy here right thinking about
this look at my semicircle with my
semicircle this is an angle of the
circumference standing on this arc over
here do you agree that's the arc
what's it can go at the center that's
standing on the same arc it's 180s at a
straight angle there it is right there
and again the angle of the center is
twice it's just really nice to see this
together those five angles sorry
property six probably six angles
standing standing oh sorry the angle two
semicircles right angle
number six angles standing on the same
arc are equal and an alternative waiting
for that for the same property is the
angles in the same segment are equal the
cyclic code ones are quite easy to
remember generally speaking which angles
we talk about in a cyclic code we're
interested in are opposite angles right
opposite angles in a cyclic
quadrilateral not equal supplementary
very good directly following on from
that you can say that the one on the
outside the exterior angle of a cyclic
quadrilateral is equal to the opposite
interior angle okay very good
meaning obtained it's we did these
fairly recently
tangent is we use this one attention is
perpendicular soothe are what's it
certainly go to seven inches the radius
conference point of contact or at its
point of contact and then we just did
ten the angle between a tangent you
don't need that line term and the court
of contact is equal to the angle in the
alternate segment eleven I might want is
a bit funny eleven we did last week at
the end of the week against our tangents
tangents from an extent point are equal
right and the last one I think that we
already have covered is fifteen fifteen
when you've got touching circles right
touching circles they just they've had
that common tangent you can say that
they're coming is how we finished how do
we start the Floyd Center properly right
so the center's and the point of contact
of those circles that's their kovin you